chute du tourisme baisse du trafic
aérien annulation d'événements sportifs
ou encore volatilité des marchés
financiers
la propagation du coronavirus à travers
le monde touche bien des secteurs la
production pétrolière en fait clairement
partie
en effet en raison du ralentissement
économique la demande en or noir s'est
elle aussi érodé sera donc l'un des
sujets de discussion au menu de la
réunion de l'opep prévue ce jeudi à
vienne
l'objectif étant pour l'organisation de
réduire la production pour faire
repartir le prix du baril à la hausse
l'arabie saoudite de facto leader de
l'opep militent pour cette solution
le royaume souhaiterait que les pays
producteurs dont fait partie la russie
réduisent au total d'un million de
barils supplémentaires leur production
quotidienne en réponse à l'épidémie
un montant nettement supérieur aux 600
mille barils évoqué dans un premier
temps mais moscou allié important du
cartel pourrait se contenter d'un statu
quo justement ce dimanche une réunion
ministérielle convoquée par vladimir
poutine s'est tenue sur le sujet je
tiens à souligner que pour le début de
la russie pour notre économie
le niveau actuel des prix du pétrole est
acceptable nos réserves accumulées y
compris le fonds national
d'investissement sont suffisantes pour
assurer une situation stable le respect
de tous les engagements budgétaires et
sociaux même en cas de détérioration de
l'économie mondiale
la situation actuelle semble tendre
quelque peu l'arabie saoudite
il s'est même murmurait que ryad
pourrait dénoncé l'entente pétrolières
avec moscou mais cette rumeur a
cependant été bien vite démenties
c'est absurde et totalement insensé nous
avons tous signé la charte de l'eau paie
plus ses continueront d'agir de manière
collective
nous sommes en contact et dialogue
constant avec tous nos partenaires de
l'opep et de l'opep plus
et même si la vie des russes venaient à
diverger de celui des saoudiens les
relations bilatérales seraient toujours
excellentes en croire le ministre russe
de l'énergie
nous sommes très satisfaits de la
coopération avec nos partenaires
saoudiens nous voulons poursuivre notre
coopération non seulement au format opep
plus mais aussi dans le cadre des
relations bilatérales
on le sent bien la sphère ne revêt pas
la même importance pour les deux
partenaires
et c'est sans doute les chiffres qui le
prouve le mieux l'arabie saoudite
fortement dépendante de ses exportations
énergétiques a besoin d'un baril à 83
dollars pour que son budget soit à l'
équilibre
la russie pour sa part a fait des
efforts ces dernières années pour
réduire sa dépendance au pétrole et n'a
besoin pour l'exercice 2009 un que d'un
baril à 42,40 dollars soit pratiquement
moitié moins avec un prix du baril qui
oscille actuellement autour des 50
dollars
on comprend alors que les enjeux ne sont
effectivement pas les mêmes pour ryad et
moscou